yeah you're absolutely right and one of
the things there's no guarantee about is
that football is even going to start on
time given what's currently happening in
the world free agency was effective but
not as much as I thought it would be the
draft clearly affected it's not going to
happen in Las Vegas it'll happen in a TV
studio somewhere and I think I don't
have the biggest ratings it will ever
have had because it's the only oasis of
actual or semi actual sports over the
next couple of months but Peter I think
the off season programs won't happen the
question is will training camp open on
time and what impact will that have on
the season it well the season even
happen on time a lot of open questions
and I hope the NFL is planning for all
possible scenarios Mike let's take them
one at a time you know let's forget
about the off season program I can't see
it happening or maybe it happens in a
very very abbreviated way say for the
first two weeks of June I don't know but
I can't see any group team activities at
the absolute earliest before June 1st
but again that's me just spitballing
being obsessed with this thing over the
last couple of weeks so then you start
to think about okay training camp will
that happen I mean probably now training
camp happens without fans do you play
the preseason games as normal and are
you even going to have I mean after
watching you know the Spring Breakers
and after watching some other elements
of our society there's a huge wedding
the other night in a Brooklyn community
that had like 500 people and the police
had to break it up and so there's
obviously people are still getting used
to the fact that you can't do group
things anymore and how much of a factor
and how long it lasts Mike ID I don't
think there's any guarantee at all that
this season starts on time I I just
don't I and I'm not trying to be an
alarmist I'm just trying to say you know
we'll see and I think there you can't
make any solid predictions about the
timing of things to happen in the future
in this country
and if you somebody would listen to that
and say oh you're crazy the football
season is six months away look what
happened in China they got they got rid
of it they aren't even having anymore
coronavirus cases Mike they dragged
infected family members away from each
other and you know they kept them for 14
days without any contact with their
families do we have the will in this
country to do that I don't think so and
so that's why okay in three months it
disappeared in in China three month and
I don't even know disappeared is
probably the wrong word but in three
months they basically got a great handle
on it in China do you seriously think in
three months we'll have a great handle
on this with what you've seen on the
news the last few days I don't yeah and
I have no problem with you being an
alarmist Peter if there had been more
alarmist several months ago we wouldn't
be in this mess right now where we're
preparing for hospitals throughout the
areas where the greatest concentration
of infected individuals are residing are
going to be overcome by the the ill and
not be able to properly care for
everyone because there were no alarmists
there were no people who were seeing and
understanding and connecting the dots
between what was happening in China and
what was inevitably going to happen here
and look I've been thinking about all
the things that could unfold Peter I
don't know where the testing technology
is going to be in September but I could
see a scenario where the NFL goes
forward in empty stadiums with every
player tested before every game and if
you're positive you're yanked from the
pool of players and you're put somewhere
until you're free from the virus if
you're negative you get to play in the
game
and I could see the NFL moving heaven
and earth to try to make that happen and
again I don't know where the testing
technology is going to be in September
but if we can get to the point where
testing is automatic and easy and
available I could see that being the
scenario where the NFL sacrifices the
revenue that would come through the
ticket office but still makes the TV
money by putting the games on TV which
would be
wildly successful and have the highest
ratings ever if we're still in this
weird existence where we're staying
indoors all the time the one thing that
I was just thinking about it and echoes
most of what you said but just think now
about if you had a debate between the
two presidential candidates on
television on a Wednesday night in
September and let's say a Tuesday night
in October before they let's say there's
two debates well I think we've all
assumed under normal conditions that
because TV ratings were down 8% NFL TV
ratings were down 8% in 2016 because
everybody went crazy over the
presidential election in two South 2016
and we've all assumed that 2020 would be
the same but now you are absolutely
right even with the gigantic ratings
that a couple of debates would engender
and all of the talk would engender about
the presidential election which I still
think would happen regardless of you
know the the state of this disease
if it happens Mike if it happens in that
way I still think the NFL will get
absurd ratings and get higher ratings
than they had last year because all
those people who said yeah I'm gonna go
take a long bike ride on Sunday or I'm
gonna go do this on Sunday or I'm going
to the mall or I'm gonna go you know go
to the beach you know with my friends I
mean if you're in California I mean
that's just I I mean again we can't see
the future but the future looks pretty
cloudy to me
and on a cloudy rainy day what do people
do they stay in and watch TV and if the
games are played in the NFL I think they
would stay in and watch that and you
know that also has to be considered
within the context of the possibility
that there are no games and the season
is a wipeout and I'm in the process of
trying to get to the bottom of this I've
asked the
I've asked the Union they haven't gotten
back to me which tells me I may be on to
something here what does the CBA say
about the possibility of the NFL not
playing its games this year do the
players still get paid and if they are
required to be paid even if the NFL
doesn't play games what does that do to
some of the teams not all of them but
some of them do you have the liquidity
to pay these guys if you're not getting
your money
do the network's still have to pay well
might for games that aren't played I
mean there's a lot of layers and levels
to that as well member back in 2011 when
the lockout was looming there were
reports that the network still had to
pay the league even if the games didn't
get played is that part of it as well
that there's a rabbit hole here that
could get very dark and very precarious
for the NFL if they don't play games
this season Mike let's let's talk about
one franchise in particular let's talk
about the New York Giants okay
so the New York Giants this is the 11th
year of MetLife Stadium and when they
started the the stadium they offered two
levels of people able to buy sweets okay
you could either buy them on a 10-year
contract or you could buy it on a 5-year
contract so in any case you know all of
their sweet I I shouldn't say all first
for all I know maybe they've got some
people who go year to year I don't know
but but the majority of their sweet
holders are up right now okay so that is
revenue that John Mayer this is a family
business okay
so John Mayer and Steve Tisch they rely
on that revenue to run this franchise
okay
and I'm not saying anybody should be
holding a canned goods drive for the New
York Giants the only point I'm making is
that in a normal year the New York
Giants right now would have money coming
in you saw this week that the Giants
basically deferred their season ticket
payments for the year until some months
down the road
now okay so you've got that and you've
got the fact that I'm sure that people
who have to pay and whatever the number
is a hundred thousand dollars to renew
their suite for this year I mean
somebody have a have the ability right
now to write a check for a hundred grand
in this environment in this climate
after the last two weeks again I'm sure
a lot of people do but will people
actually do that and the one last thing
I would say what franchise in the NFL
has the worst record in the league over
the last three years the New York Giants
are in a bad place for this whole thing
to be happening right now yeah that's a
great point and there are other teams
that are owned by families and that's
all they do or primarily what they do
like the Steelers for example you don't
have other money that's going to get you
through this or that can fund a year of
paying player salaries basically loan
yourself money from other operations
you're gonna have to go out and get a
loan and hey the good news is the
interest rates gonna be fairly low but
the bad news is that money that gets
lost when a football season goes away
never comes back and I guess the irony
and I never know when to use that word
properly but a week after we stop
talking about a potential lockout in
2021 there may be an involuntary lockout
in 2020 and a lot of issues that would
arise if and when it happens and those
would all be immaterial to the bigger
problem because if they can't play
football in September Peter that means
this thing ended up being much more of a
mess than we thought it was going in
yeah and and Mike I mean I you and I are
sitting here a week ago basically trying
to figure out are the players gonna vote
for this or the players not gonna vote
for it and just think how close it was
think of this on the average NFL team 33
players voted for 30 voted against
that's how close this was all I'm saying
is let's just say it had been reversed
how many players would be holding their
heads in their hands right now saying oh
my god what have we
not the fabulously wealthy ones but most
of the other ones and imagine the eleven
thousand players who are getting their
pensions with this new contract are
getting their pensions raised by 53
percent you know from thirty to forty
six thousand dollars in the first year I
mean you think those people might need
that money right now
so I guess the point I'm making overall
is I think it's probably a pretty good
idea they passed that CBA even though
there's still a rock-solid contingent of
players who hate it and you got to
wonder how many owners after the fact or
wishing they had voted it down so they
could yank that offer off the table and
wait a year year and a half to assess
all the damage to their broader
portfolio and then figure out how to
make as much money as they can back from
the players in the next CBA that's why
it was smart for the players to do the
deal and take the deal and I think it
was that that uncertainty that popped up
last Thursday Friday and into Saturday
that pushed this over the top by sixty
total votes I think without the
craziness that really was sparked when
the NBA pulled the plug on its season
without that I think the CBA fails and
there would have been a lot of owners
happy about it Peter you had the quote
of the month in your column that every
time the stock market goes down a
thousand points there's another owner
that wants his vote back and I think a
lot of owners would have been happy to
see this deal go away forever and then
start it all from scratch on the other
side of this crisis
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports